i want to show this clip just to talk
about how the media just cannot deal
with anything honestly here is the view
and i always warn my audience before i
play a clip of the view
just sit back don't fall out of your
seat here we go if you need to take a
drink this is the time to do it this is
the view sunny hostin defending beto
while also confusing some things about
laws in texas
they seem angrier at better or work than
they were at the massacre of 19 children
and two fourth grade teachers they were
yelling at him i'd like to see some of
that energy around gun safety i was so
shocked
that they were so angry at what he was
saying and he was saying the right
things it was totally predictable i mean
governor abbott is the person that
changed the age of owning a a gun from
21 to 18.
okay so first off i want to clarify
something what she said there was a
complete lie complete fabrication and
lie from cbs news i've got it right in
front of me abbott said wednesday after
the uvalde shooting that quote the
ability of an 18 year old to buy a gun
to buy a long gun has been in place in
the state of texas for more than 60
years so she's not only defending the
ridiculous uh outburst by beto but then
also just lying
rav this just happens every day on these
shows and people then are just confused
about what the issues are who the good
guys are and everything else
yeah it's it's really amazing how in in
almost every issue you see this again
and again with the blm stuff which was
kind of
how i started
in my journalistic career writing about
many of these big shootings like jacob
blake
and ray shard brooks atlanta and many
other cases it's like this happens again
and again where you have a high profile
case and usually the the issue for the
left becomes
the racial element so if it's a white
police officer shooting a black
suspect you see immediately this like
facts are just totally thrown out yeah
in favor of this preconditioned
narrative here we're seeing it again
with these details i mean it's like the
view is completely unwatchable to me
it's like every time i see a clip like
for my own mental health i just i can't
watch it because it's so infuriating
constantly to see them
spew this misinformation over and over
again it's like like this is the reason
why people are listening to this right
now dave and people are listening to to
joe rogan and wondering why he's so
popular this is why cnn plus
is is is in the graves r.i.p um
it's it's like because the mainstream
media is just so bad at covering the
facts they're so
disingenuous that
independent media is rising so i i think
i think in many ways that is a good
thing is that they're just openly
spewing this misinformation so that in
individual people who
know how to think can actually detect
that and listen to better media and
hopefully are watching this show right
now well to your point on what they
cover and what they don't cover 46
people were shot in chicago this weekend
six of them fatally now of course the
reason the media doesn't cover it is
because the color of the skin of the
shooters and the color of the skin of
the victims doesn't fit the narrative so
they don't cover that and as a matter of
fact i don't know if you guys saw it but
in that very press conference greg
abbott addressed that he said well you
know
because of course they're going after
him about gun laws in texas he said well
you do know that in new york and chicago
and in california they have much
stricter gun laws and people are being
shot all the time i wish it wasn't the
case and then of course new york times
wrote an article that he's race-baiting
by even saying that